elle est la création d'un homme
oberkampf qui la fabrique à partir de
1760 à jouy en josas la toile de jouy
est apprécié à l'époque pour sa grande
qualité et la précision de ses dessins
le tissu est très vite prisé par la
bourgeoisie et la noblesse française
le succès de la toile de jouy tient à la
proximité de jouy en josas avec le
château de versailles
christophe philippe oberkampf était un
visionnaire tendant
les motifs et d'un point de vue créatif
que dans sa gestion industrielle de la
manufacture la cour qui étaient
effectivement à proximité raffolait
da sa production si aujourd'hui
l'indienne ne se fabriquent plus dans sa
ville d'origine ces motifs célèbre se
décline en de nombreux produits dérivés
au sein du musée de la toile de jouy une
boutique où l'on peut trouver chaussures
bijoux trousse ou encore de la vaisselle
les plateaux qui ont été fait cette
année dans un motif bengale et ce choix
était fait surtout pour les couleurs que
manuel canovas utilise donc dans un ton
dans des tons aubergines
nous avons aussi une autre collection
des tôles qui a été fait dans un motif
dont qui a été pris dans les fonds
muséal dans le motif de l'offrande à
l'amour donc nous avons quatre coloris
qui ont été fait cette année donc dans
ce rouge basque arrose poupe et un vert
de gris
à chaque saison sa collection pour
l'automne hiver le produit phare cette
année c'est une marinière créé en
partenariat avec la marque armor lux un
vêtement fabriqué à l'occasion de
l'exposition sur le peintre franco
japonais fuji tas qui se tient en ce
moment au musée de la toile de jouy
nous avons repris donc le motif
de l'armée mais que faisait pas utiliser
énormément dans ses oeuvres et nous
avons décidé de reprendre le bateau donc
un petit sinagot qui a été mise dans les
dans les coudes hier
des marinières deux marques sont
disponibles dans la boutique collection
et création du musée de la toile de jouy
et pour panser ses produits
l'inspiration ne manquent pas au musée
qui possède un fonds de 10000 pièces de
toile de jouy de beignets effectivement
dans tous ces dessins je m'en lasse pas
je trouve toujours des choses nouvelles
c'est d'une richesse incroyable
bon moi ce que j'aime aussi beaucoup
faire c'est justement retravaillé tous
les motifs que nous avons nous dans les
réserves notamment les empreintes aussi
les choses fabuleuses
donc ça je décline avec sort énormément
de papeterie aussi dans la boutique il y
en a pour tous les goûts et pour toutes
les bourses conti de 3 à 200 euros pour
ses produits au motif de la toile venue
de jouy en josas